(awning cloth flapping)
(cars whooshing)
- Seven years ago, the destiny
of an Eminence student,
it was pretty bleak.
We were only having
about 20% of our students
persist to a post-secondary degree,
so that left the other 80%
honestly in one of our factories in town.
Our school was run down,
enrollment was declining,
our test scores had dropped.
We needed to do something drastic
in order to transform the school,
which really ended up
transforming the town.
At Eminence schools, we were
doing 21st century learning
in a 19th century building.
It was really paramount
that we create a facility
that matched our philosophy.
I am a 4th generation
alumni of Eminence schools.
I know probably better than anybody
how little money there is to go around.
I wasn't an outsider coming in,
passing attacks on people
that I didn't understand.
It was no small thing to ask the town
to give up a little bit more
to pull of this vision for these kids.
The Edhub only exists because
the Eminence community
invested in the future of every kid
that will ever walk through it.
They were willing to invest in us
to pull off something unbelievable.
- They see what's
happening with their kids,
they see the excitement and the skillset
they're beginning to come home with.
(revving)
- [Kids] Whoa.
- [Buddy] The EDhub stands for
the Experimental Davinci
Hybrid Ultra Biblotheca,
so it's kind of a fancy
newfangled library.
- This is unlike anything I've ever seen.
I mean students don't
just check out books,
they check out tools,
they use laser cutters
to create the thing they actually drew
in their notebook one day.
- It looks awesome.
- It's amazing to watch kids just flourish
in an environment where
there aren't any barriers.
(revving)
- The Edhub was designed to be
the new heart of the school.
We literally took the
traditional hallway space,
the same amount of square footage,
and just made it a circular building,
so that all the rooms flow
around the center of that space,
the Core, where all students,
kindergarten through 12th
grade, could use and utilize.
- Okay, one more drop-off,
simultaneous, go.
- [Buddy] This building has
about 30,000 square feet.
It has eight maker labs.
They range from robotics, to bio lab,
to a design thinking lab.
It has a TV stuido lab.
- [Teacher] Quiet on the set.
In five, four, three.
- And then it has
a traditional power tool lab.
- [Teacher] Let's
double-check that measurement.
(saw revs)
- I mean the space itself is so open.
Everything from just having windows,
the ability to see in all
areas at the same time,
it gives that sense of community.
- [Buddy] We wanted to be 100% functional.
Lots of the walls are moveable
magnet and writable surfaces.
- So we have 18 and 30,
it's, we're at about to.
- You know, the building's awesome,
but it's the learning that's happening
inside the EDhub that
makes it really special.
- Now let's see.
- [Student] Okay, there we go, we got it.
- It's transforming learning
because of the collaboration
skills that they learn.
They're building, creating,
designing, constructing.
All the skills that you
would use in the workplace.
- We want them to feel
like they're working
in Silicon Valley, or
at a startup company.
- [Students] Hi, hello.
- [Buddy] A lot of the
ideas that we've developed
were from the business sector
that schools had never used.
- I can remember the first time
we utilized the giant screen,
and it was just amazing to watch them
kind of take ownership
of such a large space.
They felt like experts.
In the EDhub, we see kids walk out
knowing there are a lot more possibilities
than they maybe knew about before.
- [Student] Wow.
Whoa.
- What do you see now?
- [Student] Penguin, ooh. (laughs)
- There's something powerful
about setting a goal so big
that there's no way you could pull it off.
(whooping)
That's what our town did in
the building of the EDhub.
To watch a group of people come together
and rally towards the impossible.
And our kids have been a
part of this change, as well.
And so it'll be exciting to see
what their futures look like
as a result of what they've
watched happen here.